[Music]
so once we had computers in the 1970s
that could simulate this fancy car alert
Lamborghini oh okay right right we angry
me I wish I don't think that God likes
attention
why bright neon green Lamborghini why
waste a Lamborghini upon that color
no no why waste of Lamborghini on West
Street in Manhattan
it's just weird guys when is driving
obviously to dude I can see from here
that I mean he's overcompensating for a
lot just saying cherry red
ah why not jet black y-you know that's
eco green by the way that's the
like a lot of green eco eco conscious
people so that is that electric
Lamborghini seriously but let me see if
I can hear it though it's got four
exhaust jet mondo rear tires is like
this wide probably take a turn yeah that
thing it is true by the way that hybrids
they can use their battery as the
equivalent of a supercharger so even a
typical Savannah sedan car if it's a
hybrid and you floor it you can get
extra acceleration compared to a typical
yeah in fact that the the the BMW
concept car that now is in mild
production that does that oh yeah yeah
perf winning I'm just talking about got
a friend of mine who owns one I forgot
the name of it I ate
okay is it like really badass looking at
I'm pretty sure that I okay I think it's
called the ia I could be wrong yeah it's
like it's got like a carbon fiber and
glass to the body beautiful does it
hardly weighs anything yeah it's going I
got in the car couldn't fit and I'm just
like you have to wear the car yeah I
gotta lose like 50 pounds if I'm gonna
go in there sleekly alright you know
you're neil degrasse tyson you could
just ask BMW to make a bigger I ate oh
really okay I'll do that
we just passed the because